There's a number of reasons
you'd be potentially better off
breaking your app into different activities.
Having a single monolithic activity
increases the complexity of your code,
making the creation
and management of intent filters
much harder and making it
more difficult to maintain, test,
and read your activity code.
It also increases the risk
of tightly coupling independent components
and makes it much more likely
to introduce security risks
if the single activity includes
both sensitive information
and information that's safe to share.
A good rule of thumb
is to create a new activity
whenever the context changes.
For example, displaying
a different kind of data, while switching
from viewing to entering data.